>>> AND NOW, JENNIFER COOLIDGE
IS IMPRESSED BY CHRISTMAS STUFF.
>> HI, I'M JENNIFER COOLIDGE.
I LOVE CHRISTMAS.
OH, LOOK AT THIS.
A BIG SOCK FULL OF GIFTS.
YOU KNOW, THE ULTIMATE STOCKING
STUFFER IS A FOOT.
AH, CHRISTMAS LIGHTS.
SO COLORFUL, YOU KNOW, ONE YEAR,
I GOT THE BLINKING ONES, I LEFT
MY CHRISTMAS TREE ON ALL NIGHT
AND LEARNED MY CAT WAS
EPILEPTIC.
>> OH, THAT'S REALLY GOOD!
DID YOU WRITE THIS SONG?
>> DID I WRITE "JINGLE BELLS"?
>> YEAH.
>> NO.
>> THEN WHO DID?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
SOME GUY.
>> MM, A BIG CUP OF EGGNOG!
KIND OF WEIRD.
TASTE LIKE I'M DRINKING SANTA'S
[ BLEEP ]!
OH, HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
I FORGOT TO MAKE A WISH.
WOW, CHRISTMAS PRESENTS.
COULD BE ANYTHING IN HERE.
I WANT TO SHAKE IT.
GIVE ME SOME MUSIC!
♪ ♪
SOUNDS LIKE AN ANTIQUE DOLL WITH
ONE EYE.
OH.
I WAS RIGHT!